hello hello
hello hello everybody
we are going to get started here
momentarily
we're just going to wait for people to
filter
in
and i'm going to get a chat window up
here just so i can
get you all i'll try to mention your
names
i can never do it very well hello devops
tech techier i'm from ohio
in the united states hello
hello quincy thanks for having me on
again
all right i'm going to increase this
just a little bit more there we go
all right so we're going to get started
in about 30 to 60 seconds
again i just want people to
filter in a little bit more
all right
you can't see the workspace
well hopefully you can right
okay so let's go ahead and get started
so
the first thing i did a live stream here
last week
uh exactly one week ago at the same time
and for those of you who missed it you
don't know who i am i'm gary simon i've
been a ui ux designer
and a front-end developer for the last
20 years i've been doing the teaching
thing for the last 10 years on my own
youtube channel
which you can check out right here
so it's at youtube.com forward slash
design course
and you can subscribe up i do these live
streams here on my channel i call it the
negative space
i'm going to be doing the same show
essentially here and if you like this
you know go ahead and subscribe up
uh at my channel also designcourse.com
that's my site i'm relaunching it in a
few months time
last week i did mention this site and i
told you to enter your email if you want
to be notified when that goes live and
of course with my luck
the server that the api endpoint was on
at media temple completely went down so
a lot of you tried to enter your email
and
it gave you an error message so again
enter
it and this time it will work assuming
media temple servers
stay up all right and in order to
participate
you need to go to twitter and you can
tweet your
user interface design this could be a
live website
it could be just a figma or adobe xd
prototype
i and also use the hashtag live ui ux
review
all this information should be in the
description here in youtube
all right so i'm not going to be taking
these in any particular order i picked
out a few initially
and so what we're going to be doing is
i'm going to be reviewing your ui
designs
and i'm going to be considering both
user interface design and user
experience design when i look at these
so user interface design would mean i'm
taking a look at things like
white space alignment scale
typography color and contrast in visual
hierarchy
and when it comes to user experience
design or ux design
i'm going to be asking myself you know
it doesn't make sense to do this or that
here
uh is it going to be hard for the user
to use is the verbiage you're using
makes sense
and so we'll also ask at the end of my
little review
i'll ask you who are watching in the
chat here to give it a rating of one
being the worst and 10 being the best
i try not to look because i don't want
you guys to poison the well
and i'll give my rating afterwards and
we'll see if we agree
or not all right so the whole goal here
is just to improve
if i don't review your design don't
worry about it that much it's not a big
deal you're still going to
gain a lot of insight based on what i
have to say
i what's happening with other people's
submissions
all right so i've picked out a few like
i said initially
and i'm just going to get started right
here with this particular entry
so when i look at this design
let me push this over so we don't see
the background there we go
so when i look at this design
what i immediately think is
first of all there's not a lot of white
space from this little graphic
and the the top portion here so we can
immediately push this whole section
down away from the navigation up top
second
we're lacking what's called visual
hierarchy now
again this is a ui design fundamental
it's not a ux topic
i and i've talked about this before in
my last stream
but nailing your visual hierarchy is
very important because
what it means is i'm not sure exactly
where i should look
first when i consider all this text
right here
i'm not sure where to look so you need
to use
your ui design fundamentals such as
scale
color and contrast and alignment in
order to
reinforce that visual hierarchy or in
other words
direct the eye where you want to see it
so let me just show you what i mean real
quick if i get out the dev tools here
and i take this element right here okay
well what we could do is we can font
weight
bold it because i think this is going to
be the most
one of the most important parts this is
kind of like the headline of the website
right
and i think we could also take color so
color and contrast we're going to
increase the contrast by making the
color white
so now all of a sudden we see this the
eye is directed to this section
much more than this stuff down here so
now we have a place to actually look
it's probably a little bit longer of a
headline than i would want
we could also probably slightly increase
the font size so what's 2m
that's a little bit too big maybe 1.3 m
units maybe line height 1.3
m as well and now we really can see that
this is an important element it's the
one thing that we want
people to to be able to see all right so
next up after this
impressed already hit this button and so
i'm not going to hit it but it's it's
basically a
it's a mail to you know their email so
it's going to open up my email
client um i wouldn't advise doing that
now this person is doing something witty
which is i see you don't just hit random
button on the internet good for you
let me flex some of my skills you don't
want to trick
your visitors i understand you're trying
to be unique and witty but you don't
really want to trick your visitors
because
here's the problem sometimes somebody
will quickly
look at a site they might just read this
headline
and then see this button like why would
i want to hit this button i'm exiting
out of this site
they're not going to bother reading this
part down here where you said
you don't just hit a random button so
that's something to take into
consideration
the skills uh progress bar i talk about
this a lot in fact i did a video today
on my own youtube channel where i talk
about
the top 10 worst ui design trends of
2020
and this is this is actually one of them
it's one of the recent ones that i've
seen
i you don't want to put a progress bar
in my opinion
on with your skills simply because what
if somebody
wants somebody who's proficient in c and
they see
when they stack it up against all your
other skill sets
it's gonna it only tells them that this
person's not very good
and here we go again okay okay i agree
using progress bro for skills is not a
really good idea so you're being witty
but you might be confusing people
because they may not read this
all right so all in all uh that's my
review here there's a lot more but i
have to move on what do you people think
this person should get for a rating one
being the worst and 10 being the best by
the way if i refresh this you'll see the
original design
and this is my changes to reinforce the
visual hierarchy so if i refresh this
you'll see you're not really sure where
you should look first so
let me know in the youtube chat
one being the worst 10 being the best
and we'll see if you guys agree with me
and i'll give you about 15 seconds until
i start seeing some roll
in
so i'm just kind of scrolling up here
trying to think of what i would give
this one
personally i'm probably
going to say around i could see
all the comments on the side of my view
my peripheral vision i'm not looking at
your answers i'm going to go ahead and
say
a good old
5.3 or so
all right so looking at these
we have some eight seven five two five
seven
six six six five five okay yep uh pretty
much
around there we had some variants there
quite a bit so
another one that i wanted to review here
is from this user right here so
there's nothing wrong with absolute
simplicity of course we have a lot of
simplicity here we have a lot of
white space there's just not much
happening here
one problem is is i we see we have hi
i'm you know your name and then
underneath it looks like a button
i want to click on it but it's not a
button so i might rethink that
i would also work on and this is a ux
specific idea
the ad copy here i think you can
probably do a little bit more with this
area to fill it out
um even also taking this left column
here in this right column
and trying to construct it in such a way
that it fills out more of the user
interface
also there's no call to action this
looks like it could be a call to action
because it's a button but it's not but
so there's not really a call to action
if you want people to scroll down
at least do the floating animated
scroll down area i'm a fan of having
buttons though
just to give people something to click
on to go right where you want them to
outside of that we have another section
right here
now if you look at
the code for this this is whole section
there's like a
i actually like the background here it's
a really cool sort of
you know very barely visible background
it has nice texture to it
it this whole section is set up on a
height 100 viewport heights or 100 vh
in css and that's good that's fine i
like that
but this section right here has not been
centered vertically so we have all this
unnecessary white space
so you want to address that next up this
is unnecessary
this whole me thing because you already
said about right here you have a title
it says a little about me that's all you
need
so you don't want to be redundant in
that sense so i would just delete that
and then take this center it vertically
so if you're using the grid that would
be like place item
or place content uh center and that'll
automatically do it for you
another thing i noticed this is
something i see all the time
unfortunately is on the this is a
desktop
view i this would be right here on a
mobile device right where it makes sense
to use a hamburger menu
if you have enough links to justify it
but out here
you only have three different links
the pro this is a ux issue you don't
want people to have to unnecessarily
click
in order to access a navigation you only
do that
if you don't have enough physical room
to give them access to so you only have
home
or wait me work find me just put those
three
right here that way people can click on
them and access that
quite quickly next up this part's not
too bad there's no big ui or ux
issues occurring here although um i
guess
if you only have two examples you can go
ahead and fill them out but it might
make more sense to
put these maybe in a column of three and
then list out more at the same time
all right so that's my review here what
do you
think that this person should get for a
rating one being the worst and ten being
the absolute best you've ever seen i'll
give you about 15 to 20 seconds
all right i'm going to
give this a rating of probably
let's see there's not a lot of like
really bad things happening here
so i'm just going to do i like kind of
this section here
could improve on the contrast um i'm
going to say
a
6.1 maybe or so
yeah there we go very good and by the
way everybody
please try not to spam don't give your
same answer multiple times in the text
chat it just clutters it up way too much
it makes the life of the moderators
difficult um
so yeah just only mention your your
answer once all right
so next up i have another one that i
wanted to showcase that somebody
submitted
all right so what's interesting about
this example here
is um two days ago i released a video
about using photographs
for your landing pages specifically like
in the hero section of a landing page
just like in this context and there's
nothing wrong with doing this
um i think they used it and they did it
correctly because they did
push the darkness on this image um well
enough
so that you can see the type sitting on
top of it a lot of times people try to
show you the full image without
darkening it and then it's hard to read
everything on top so they did that well
um but if you do want to see
alternative more modern ways to approach
this type of design this type of layout
check my video
um because i show a way to do this so
that you have a full
nice vibrant image that is seamless and
kind of worked into the user interface
but for what this is welcome to foodika
visit blogs i would probably fill this
out with a little bit more content
and maybe a sub headline at the very
least
visit blogs i'm not sure you know where
this would take me exactly
so apparently this is a blog and this is
what you want people to end up on
right here the most i actually like the
design it's pretty solid from what i see
here
but it does make me wonder if you really
want people to go to the blog
why do you have kind of like a splash
page really
i mean i would take him straight to the
content as much as possible
so coming down here chef's
choice weekly special click here
okay so i'm trying i'm still kind of
confused about what this is
exactly like the purpose of the site
and so that sometimes that's a ux issue
as well sometimes that gets lost and you
really want to
address this information as much as
possible let me close out my
my email client um outside of that just
looking at the ui design it's
itself it's pretty solid here there's
some minute things
um for instance we have a certain amount
of white space between these two columns
but then
over here it's like half it's really
a good idea to use consistent white
space especially in the same section
between columns and rows
so that's a really small gripe also
another small gripe i have down here
looking at this
email form submit there's a nice
all-around well-applied white space
within this button around the text
however if we come over here just
slightly i'll increase the size
one thing that throws things off these
are very new small things but if you if
you have a lot of them on a design it's
just
it's not going to look good and you may
not know why but
what i would do in this case there's not
enough white space
on the left right here compared to the
top
and the bottom as well as what's applied
over here so that's very small my new
issue that is worth
and it's easy to address so if we see
padding
the element is right here maybe we can
put one m
unit
1m on the left
so now that small change just
brings everything together so if i
refresh this you'll see what it goes
back to it's just slightly off
all right so that is my review for this
one
what do you people think that this
person should get for a rating one being
the worst you've ever seen and 10 being
the best
you have 15 to 20 seconds
so let's see me what would i give this
i mean this is a nice photograph it is
up here
i'm not too happy about
uh position fixed backgrounds here
i think it's a little bit disorienting
to people so i probably wouldn't do that
but this is pretty solid overall
probably going to be our highest rated
one so far to the point so i'm going to
give this one
a let's see a
seven just a straight up seven i think
would work pretty well
for that example all right
so i have a couple more that i just
chose before we began and then i'll
start looking at the
twitter feed for the hashtag
all right so there's a number of issues
with this particular example and
in this case i would say the person who
designed this
really needs to understand
those ui design fundamentals that i
mentioned before
because a lot of this is ui design based
not necessarily ux based
so like a like i mentioned at the
beginning of the stream white space
alignment scale typography color and
contrast and visual hierarchy
you need to understand all of those and
then gain practice applying them
so first and foremost we have a
navigation up here
but then we have this small amount of
text
kind of really close so there's an issue
of a lack of white space first and
foremost
and there's also i it doesn't really
make sense
also from a ux standpoint to have this
type right here when you have
a headline and then a sub headline over
here so it feels very disconnected and
this just seems randomly placed
so what i would do is i would take this
whole section and
i would oh and by the way just a front
end development tip here you don't want
to have like two h1s here
for this these would probably be the
best
used as like paragraph tags right here
so i would remove those
so now we simplify the top that looks
better
and it makes more sense also you want to
make sure
as much as you can
you want to make sure that your design
is working well
responsively and notice this button
it's touching the edge here and it just
doesn't look very good
in this case so you want to fix that as
much as possible
next up there's an issue with visual
hierarchy in the topography
so yes this is bigger and this is
slightly smaller
but it's still not separated enough
visually so i would
reduce the scale here and maybe even
make the font weight normal
and not bold and then that you see that
clear separation between those two
elements
and the view my work is unnecessarily
large you're going to want to take that
down quite a bit
also i would say this area this little
blob
sort of bezier curve it doesn't look 100
smooth to me it looks like somebody took
this into maybe an illustrator a vector
drawing application
and where you place and how you place
the anchor points is very important when
it comes to creating these
very smooth blob effects so i would just
i try to remedy that as well your
navigation too much white space in
between each individual link
you'd want to fix that and yeah so
that's just
uh my quick review of this landing page
what do you
people think this person should get for
a rating one being the worst in 10 being
the best
i don't agree that it's a seven i want
you i want to judge
how it currently is
for me
i think it will give this one a rating
of
yeah it's going to have to be a little
bit on the lower side just because
there's a lot of issues
so i'm going to give this one a flat
4. yes i think that's fair enough now if
you fixed all those issues that i
mentioned yeah you can bump this up to
like a 7 or so
or 7.5 based on the content that is here
and how it's presented
all right seems like most of you agree
all right next up there's one more that
i had that was
pre-planned here
all right so a couple issues right away
that i'm noticing
are this graphic right here
look how close it is to the navigation
you know you
definitely want to give that white space
there's nothing worse than something
that's just like sitting there
in the navigation or right next to it
that's just taking focus
away so margin top you know
maybe seven m units there we go
that's a lot better looks a thousand
times better
next up we have the headline in the sub
headline
those are in terms of typogra
strictly speaking of typography those
are done well
this is light this is bold and
it's also larger so it's done well but i
would say there's
probably a little bit too much white
space between both of these
and then next up here's here's a ux
issue
i this doesn't make sense in my opinion
it doesn't make sense to use this little
linkedin embed right here
for a few reasons first of all it
doesn't really quite fit this design
i i understand that you you want them to
go to your linkedin
but at the same time you already have a
linkedin
right here along with all of your other
elements and so
if you really want them to go to your
linkedin i would
simply put a button like this and that's
it i want to put this whole thing right
here
and that way it would really help the
flow of your design a lot better because
this just does
it seems out of place right here um
next up all right so i actually like
this section here
um where we have the two columns right
here and i strive for i
i like that that's really set up well
but
i would say there's an issue with color
there's also
an issue with um you making this
the description bold and making that
kind of stand out more
rather than the title of each or the
label of each of these four sections so
let me show you real quickly how i would
refactor
this particular design so first of all
it's kind of also hard on the eyes a
little bit too hard on the eye so i
would change this color
to maybe something that's a
darker desaturated bluish or so
i like that um and then inside of it
we'll take these elements
and we'll do color white
and we're also going to font weight bold
those now i know it looks ugly right now
but don't worry we're going to fix
all of that and then you might want to
say
okay maybe we'll make the color white
here and that's fine
but you know what we could still
increase
the or improve the visual hierarchy of
this section
because these being 100 white and these
being 100 white
kind of makes a little bit hard to
quickly scan this area so what i would
do is instead of making it white
here's my little trick we take the color
picker and you could do this in figma or
adobe xd
if you're working in a prototyping
software or design we take the
background that's sitting on
now of course it's hidden now i like to
take the color picker and just go
up a little bit and notice where it says
i'm not sure if you can see it here
color con color it says contrast ratio
3.14 you want to get that up into where
it this gives you a positive reading a
check mark so right there
is probably the minimum double a and
this is according to
the wcag 2.0 color contrast guidelines i
know that's kind of like a word solid
there
look it up i've done videos on this you
want to make sure you have a minimum
level
of contrast and that way you'll have a
much more accessible design for those
who have visual impairments
so like right around there would be
pretty good i like that so
look at this i i like this a lot better
compared to what it was before i'm going
to refresh and show you the original so
this is what i had
and now look at the original so this is
just kind of harder to read in my
opinion
if you wanted to keep the same
background color you can but at least
bold these up and make these
uh not quite as bold as they are or just
make this a lot bolder
all right so that's my quick review here
for this design
what does everyone think this person
should get for a rating one being the
worst in 10 being
the absolute best
i'm going to make an adjustment to
myself real quick while you get your
answers in
there i wanted to improve myself
the color was off with me all right so
for this one
i'm going to go ahead and give this a
rating of
yeah i think this is a solid
6.3 so yes i am using the point systems
i'm getting a little bit more specific
10 just isn't enough or just using the
ones place all right so it seems like
a negative 10. that's not nice all right
[Music]
okay so yeah it seems like
yep you're welcome let's go ahead
and look at some of the ones that have
been submitted here
so let me refresh this and
we'll check out just a few of these um
and
see what how i can do this off the cuff
which i i do this
for the most part um this is i'm going
to try to find
sites or examples that are live on in
the browser because i like to also
just see it fully realized as opposed to
a prototype most of the time
um okay gary please review this one
uh so this is an aesthetic
like a makeup company all right
all right okay so
first thing the first thing that in
a good thing is if i have to sit and
stare out of design for a while
in order to find something really wrong
that's a good thing
but there is something that i think
could definitely be approved here
and that is the orientation the layout
of this form
also there could be accessibility issues
because if this is just an email
placeholder for the label it gets hidden
i mentioned this in the last stream i
have to mention it every time i do one
of these live streams because
too many people rely on the placeholder
value as a label
but the problem is once you start typing
in it the label goes away
and then sometimes people they might get
up from their computer and come back
they forget
what is this form field i have no clue
what i'm doing here
so it's always nice to have at least a
floating label
i in you can't go wrong when you're
actually using
a label element in html
because it will never be hidden all
right
all right next up when you have just
three elements
form elements like this having them
float next to each other like one here
one here
and then your name right here and then
request it makes more sense to collapse
those all each on their own row
so that way it's a lot more easy for
people to fill out
and just scan with their eyes so i
wouldn't agree with having these in two
different columns outside of that
let me scroll down see what else is
happening here
all right i think you could probably
increase the size
or at least the positioning so you have
this card here
you want to take this and make sure that
this centered vertically within that
card
same thing here i would probably
increase the visual hierarchy here or
improve it by taking
these elements on the left and making
them bold
and that way you can easily separate
them from the prices over here
and there is a lot of kind of card based
design there's a lot of type here
so i might think about possibly
restructuring that
to make it a little bit less i don't
know maybe i'm wrong about that
um i just i think it probably be
improved visually
if you bold these up over here and you
center things over here
the type is a little bit small in areas
like right here chin
cheek and nose i thought that said check
for a second
a little bit small on the small side so
you definitely
want to rethink that possibly maybe
increase it
um i really like the type you're
definitely
reinforcing that that higher end
feel uh this this feels luxurious to me
and that's
kind of what serif fonts tend to do but
so i think that's done well
there's good white space here inside of
these containers so that's all working
out well
you might want to separate
this section right here
with the about section in a different
content container perhaps
maybe making this part like a lighter
color maybe even white or close to it
and that way it kind of gives more
structure to the layout having them
inside of individual containers
all right and then same comment with the
uh this this area right here
um make sure you're using labels or at
least floating labels
all right what do you think this person
should get for a rating one being
the worst and 10 being the best
also i'd probably try to increase the
quality of your photo here you can tell
there's
some decent pixelation here so
definitely look into that
i'm going to give this one a
let's think here
i'm going to give it a
6.9
and it seems like most of you are
agreeing with that
already all right who is next
up let's see here
let me scroll down just because i don't
want to people i want to make it random
like i don't want to do only the latest
submitted so i'm just going to scroll
down randomly and then
just check some of these out um
let's see here i've been doing a lot of
portfolios so i kind of want to
change that up first project somebody's
first project i'm going to move it off
screen first
and then check it out okay
now this is your first project i'm
hoping
that it's not based on a template
because if i'm
if i'm reviewing designs i don't want to
base it on a template um that somebody
created already so i'm just going to
make the assumption that this
is not a template the reason i say that
because if it's your first design this
is actually
pretty good for somebody's first design
so
looking at this there's some um let's
see here strange
things happening just because we have no
navigation that's the only reason i say
that now
you don't always need a navigation if
you have an extremely
simple one-page site you know maybe you
have one purpose and that's it
so maybe that's the case here again once
again we
have this issue with the forms i'm going
to assume these aren't floating you can
never know until you click inside of it
to see if they
somehow float up so if i do full name
yeah unfortunately they're hidden also i
wouldn't make the actual type
white because white on this light gray
is not enough contrast i guarantee that
would that would fail the contrast
checker
so you want to use labels here um
also this doesn't make sense to me right
here having the contact button
right outside of the container right
here that i would not do that
also i would not use this gray color
right here this it's kind of like a mid
mid gray eye for using as like uh colors
like for like backgrounds and stuff like
the background of this little card here
almost never works it's very hard to
make it look good so i would change that
color to something else
so for instance i would take
get out of there i i dealt with this
last time okay there he goes
so i would take this
background and i would make it something
that fits you know you're using this
color right here
we could use that that looks better
already just that change you could go
darker
maybe it will create a little bit more
saturation
or you know i probably say this one is
if you're gonna do this that would be
best and then also i would change uh let
me change that again really quickly
um also i would change
the gray here uh that doesn't that what
that
because it's great now it doesn't really
look that good
so i don't see the background
property for this
let's see if i can still change it so if
i change background
no don't do that i was just typing blue
so i have access to the color picker
i would take this and
maybe make it darker probably make it a
little bit darker like that
and then fix up the color here as well
because the gray doesn't fit very well
so if i refresh we'll see the original
and i'm just not a big fan of that one
right there outside of that
looking at this this is pretty good
right here you can read it
we have a lot of borders borders are one
of those things that are
for the most part outdated but
it's not horrible here um so i'm just
clicking on this
all right so there's not much else i can
do i can't scroll down
so i will conclude this rating a one
being the worst time being the best
what do you think this person should
receive
yeah you're right you know we could
actually because this is the call to
action right here we could make this
stand out look a lot more we could take
the
the blue this color this button put it
inside here
and then make it like orange or we can
make this whole section really stick out
and make it orange as well because
orange is a good complementary color
uh to to blue i mean yeah to like a blue
color here so
um
now of course the gray inside of it
really makes it look ugly
but that could definitely work so for
this i'm going to give this a rating
for what it is and also especially
considering if this is really something
they did from scratch it's their first
design
it's it's pretty impressive but as it is
not considering that
as it stands i'm probably going to give
this a
just a flat
sometimes i i get stalled like 5.9 or so
but considering it's their first design
if they designed it i i have to give it
like an eight or nine
uh for a first time for sure you should
see some of my stuff
back in the late 90s when i started not
good all right
so next up i let's see here
let's come up here down i'm trying to
stay away from portfolios just because
there's so many portfolios i've done
already
let's see so there's so many portfolios
this one might not be a portfolio so let
me check
all right so we'll really quickly
spend some time on this one this one
needs a lot of work
um first of all you don't want to have
your image here
not being fluid you don't want this to
happen next up we have an issue with
contrast you can't hardly read this
remember i talked about using
backgrounds
photographs as backgrounds you want to
push them off so they're water marks
so you decrease the brightness
and you darken the whole thing and then
that way we can see what's up you don't
want to make
um this sort of thing comic sans uh and
mix your typefaces so that's bad
topography right there
you don't want to have glows on them as
well on your text it pretty much will
never turn out looking well
um we also have an issue here um with
just the cards being spaced out like
this
and kind of disconnected with the type
underneath it not being encased in them
so yeah we're not going to bother with a
rating for this one just because there's
really not
enough there but i in that kind of case
definitely go back to the basics in
terms of ui design and learn about all
those fundamentals that i mentioned
before
next up i this is a project that is
designed to develop for a startup
company
so let's check that out always moving it
off to the side of the screen
just to be safe okay
now looking at this okay so
we have the logos already here
and i will say now i've been i was an
identity designer a logo designer
uh and that's all i did for about five
to six years
of my career and i've i've designed
countless logos and i can say right now
that this logo needs to be
rethought because this looks like it
says peeve
not speed this s is too abstract so i
i'm not sure if you have control over
this or if this is your
your project but i would definitely
change that because that's an issue
people are going to think your business
name is peeve so
outside of that in terms of uh ux and
your
your ad copy uh that you're using or
your your web copy
speed does not make sense here um
i would this is
first of all in terms of the visual
hierarchy you're placing all the
emphasis on the name
and i don't think that makes sense to me
the emphasis should be on the headline
and identifying what exactly is
happening here what is this business
about what is this website about
welcome to the world of faster
deliveries that's what we want to know
we don't want to have this huge emphasis
this big
white container with the business name
so i would change that the discover more
when you hover over it i would get rid
of that
uh the drop shadow it just it doesn't
work well in my opinion it just
adds unnecessary uh clutter or if you're
going to do it
make it be more of an afterthought don't
make it be so obvious
as it is um coming down oh also
the navigation i wouldn't have an
underline under
every single nav item maybe
the one that you're currently on like
this is the home page or the about page
i'm not sure which
it's obviously the home page or whatever
um but not every single one of them just
because the big thick borders
add unnecessary clutter also
there's been a lot of there's been
several studies about
people expecting the a home link
uh in your navigation people expect to
see a home button so they can get back
to
the home page or what they perceive as
being the home page so that's also
something just to think about
people want to see a home button
scrolling down here
all right so now i scroll down we're
left with just this for quite a while
which is a big empty area so i would
make this
come in quicker also this is too large
on this resolution at least i'm not sure
how responsive it is and it's not
responsive so the layout breaks i'm not
sure if
maybe you didn't get to that part yet
because this looks like it's
designed only for desktop so you
definitely want to fix that if that's
something that you haven't considered
we have issues with the topography and
the visual hierarchy
what we do is more which is the label
that needs to be
the thing that catches people's eye
their eye the most
i this yeah this is
way too large you don't want it
overlapping need more white space also
has alignment issues so there's a lot
happening here
that could definitely be fixed
this is probably the best part i kind of
like this although i would have more
white space
away from the center line here
all right so that is my rating one being
the worst 10 being the best
what do you people think this person
deserves i'll give you about 15 to 20
seconds
i will be doing this for about 15 more
minutes or so
and then we will conclude
what do i want to give this design
i'm personally thinking somewhere in the
fives
the type is just way too large i mean
this could be cut down way down way way
way way down
along with these icons here as well by
like
hundreds of percent down i'm going to
give this one
just a flat
5.0 maybe 4.6
or 4.9 or so seems like
most of you are disagreeing with me you
think it should be rated higher
okay well that's okay
not everybody can be 100 right like me
i kid all right uh let's go up back top
here
and i'll check out some of these that
were submitted um
let's see here we'll do latest
okay so here is a esport site
i did all right um it's in a different
language
so i'm going to use the google translate
option
or at least i'm going to try to
all right we have some we have quite a
bit of animation occurring here
all right so let's refresh this
now it's an esports site so we have to
take that
into consideration um when i'm doing
this review because
you know the logo being intense the
animation intents in the background
video being intense you know that's more
forgivable and acceptable um or maybe
even warranted
um given the nature of the site and what
it's about
having said that i would say there's
probably a little bit
too much animation occurring in the
background so it's a little bit
disorienting
looking at this so you could still keep
the video based background
but i would probably try to choose clips
that are
a little bit less in motion all right so
reduced motion
also i do think though that they've done
a very good job
of making it more of a watermark and
decreasing
the contrast and making it a desaturated
100 percent
grayscale so that works quite well
the logo placement i would like to see
it up a little bit higher
because it's kind of further down on the
page and also
you're missing something that's really
important in my opinion yeah we know
this is about esports because it says it
here in your logo
however what else is about we need to be
a little bit more specific and use
all this space wisely um because
every page should have a goal and so i
don't know what i'm supposed to do here
i don't know what type this is
like is this a is this news is this a
news site
is this um is this like a
of a person or a company that has esport
events like i'm not really sure what's
happening here just
yet
or is this a team like is this an
esports like clan
i used to be i used to play quake 2 like
crazy
and i was in clans back then this is
back in late 90s and early 2000s
so i think we need to address what
exactly
this site is about a little bit more in
this area
but overall there's some cool things
happening here issue with alignment
if we we can see right here it says sun
we have the title
subtitle but then pushed over about 20
pixels is the description
you want those to be on the same exact
column also
um i would work with the
i'll probably put this in all into a
paragraph and i would not
separate them with lines right here
because it just looks
a little bit too disconnected and a
little bit
too dis uh a little bit too unorganized
all right so what do you think this
should be click on matches somebody
wants me to click on matches
all right one issue here
the match with this little logo hard to
see
um nonetheless i'm not going to review
the whole site though we don't have
enough time for that
one being the worst 10 being the best
let me know in the comments what you
think
esports automatically zero
oh wait
it looks like oh i thought this was
fixed it was based on like scroll
position
i'm going to give this right here
i'm going to give this a rating of
a 6.3
or so
some people i tell you
just because you spam it 20 times 10
doesn't make it 10. i'm sorry
all right okay let's continue on
my first commercially used website oh
okay i love this i love these types here
all right i'm going to this is another
one i have to
translate
if you hear a strange noise in the
background that is the garage door
opening up right now underneath me
it'll be done in a second all right
so hair stylist all right so
another video background this one this
background seems to be pretty decent
because it is darker
and you can clearly see the elements on
top of it
um i still need something more to be
desired in this area
where it just says hair stylist and then
the name of the hair stylist
i might want to do something a little
bit more unique
or include these but have these be like
sub elements
or subtitles and then use
something like this size for an actual
headline that says something very
interesting
and pertinent or relevant about your
business i'm coming down here
this section right here seems like
um it could definitely use
improvement on the topography side of
things so like this
wow we're using font
properties here font size
2m units margin bottom
okay that's not working sometimes these
aren't working well
depending on which element i'm choosing
who are using brs i wouldn't use
the break elements as well but i would
push this down
as well and maybe even restructure this
um what i would do this stuff right here
i probably push
i would take this whole car this whole
section and put it down
beneath the about me section or even
down
further and also a nice thing to do
is i all this location information
is to maybe embed like a google maps
area maybe in the right column and then
have this
situated to the left column outside of
that
more white space above this section
because these are two different sections
you have about me and what i offer so i
put more white space or margin top
on this element to separate it out more
um coming down all right so it's fine
you use placeholders as long as you do
have labels and this person does have
labels so that's good
um sometimes though i think you don't
need to have the placeholder value if
you're dealing with
obvious form elements such as the email
and the subject it just seems repetitive
in my opinion and it does clutter it up
unnecessarily
send button i would probably get rid of
the the white outline
all right one being the worst 10 being
the best what do you all believe
this person should receive as a rating
a abd you saw jean or whatever your name
is
please stop doing that don't spam
i'm going to give this one here and this
is hey this is a great job for your
first
commercially accepted you know live
website
so you're definitely on the right track
i'm going to give this one
a
6.5 or so
all right next up
we'll probably do one more or so
depending on the time that we have
left we have about six minutes
all right i'm coming down
this is a well i don't want to deal with
figma links honestly just because we
have so many
that we can choose not a portfolio
all right okay it is not a portfolio
very good okay
so speaking of trends
um these trends i i forget
what was it um i forget the website name
where you can find many of these type of
design illustrations which are fine to
use but i think
because so many people use them they're
overused now
and you can never go wrong uh trying to
use something that's more unique
um but still this works well for what it
is
looking at the rest of this i see a lot
of blue and not much variation in the
type
um in terms of the color at least i
think we could possibly
improve that a little bit by changing
this
maybe possibly making this darker or
making this text darker
outside of that though the it is i like
how it's set up
this is set up pretty well um
in terms of the size and the visual
hierarchy
um again like i said everything's just
blue i think
a little bit of variation would help in
one way or the other
now here's a good thing two different
sections right here
separated by this background a good
amount of equal
consistent white space between the top
of this element
in this section right here and the
bottom of these elements
and where this section ends right here
so that's that's one of those small
things that really helps out a design
i like this nice blue a lot smaller
sub labels or subtitle i should say
versus the title
and this right here is a little
description all three of these elements
are designed
differently in terms of topography and
that really helps it
out a lot
now this part seems kind of disconnected
to me
um i don't know why okay everything up
to this point has been
within this container with a column
starting here
and then a column ending here
but then this is it breaks out of the
columns structure and i don't like that
so this shouldn't be based on fluid this
should these should all be moved
together
uh inside of the same container you
would still have white space between
them
but not as much
buy now button should stick out more
make that white
not this background color that way it
will really stick out as an option to
click
and then down here i would probably just
make this bold maybe darker
all right what do you think this person
should get for a rating one being the
worst and 10 being the best
quincy yes uh you're right i it's just i
i've seen them
these these images so much i
but yeah on draw.ceo is exactly what i
was thinking
there are so many of those illustrations
it's it's insane i'm not even sure if
like are they perhaps using some sort of
like
ai generated or something because
there's so many of them it's it's insane
i i like them it's just one of those
things that i see everybody using
and you're right a victim of our own
success for this one i'm going to go
ahead and give
i really like this section here this is
like the best design section simple but
it works well
i'm going to go ahead and give this one
a
7.1 yeah
oh this time quincy gave a less a lesser
rating
all right we're gonna do one more and
then we'll go ahead and wrap this
up so i'm gonna come back up and refresh
all right um who do i want to
try now um
a music website this this person said
it's their first
music website and so
because i consider myself a hobby
musician we're gonna check that out
really sad news yesterday one of the
greatest guitar players eddie van halen
died
unfortunately if you go to my twitter
you can see me
playing attempting to play the eruption
solo
from van halen so definitely check that
out shameless plug
all right um okay we so we have
alignment issues here right away
the logo which i like it's very simple
starts here but then everything breaks
out outside of it and we have another
columns
right here this right here should all
start on this line this column this
invisible column
that's set the tone is set right there
by this right here so
move that into the left and then also
take these headphones which i like this
this background move that over to the
right as well
you'll have to because this will be over
here naturally
so music is life it's an important part
of her life
as it is a way of expressing her
feelings as well as emotions
and there's a link to happy music and i
assume this takes us to a youtube link
because there's a youtube icon in it
so i'm not really sure though what i
guess
it's it's uh maybe a curated playlist
of happy music so i'm still confused
about what exactly
is happening here or what the purpose of
this site is so i think you need to
elaborate on that a little bit more
coming down we have a lot of white space
down here
from the bottom of this section which is
defined by this higher contrast element
you know the these beats headphones but
then we have this tiny bit right here
it'll look a lot better if you take this
padding using absolute pixel
elements here and we jumped this up to
like
10 m units and this already looks a lot
better
same thing right here we have this tiny
little bit of white space
i would scale down the size of this
photograph quite a bit
but what refresh i'm going to refresh
and you'll see the original
and it's just it feels so clamped and
cluttered when you don't have enough
white space
all right what does everybody think this
person should get for a rating
one being the worst and 10 being the
best
somebody said how to hack facebook with
html
if somebody could do that they uh they
deserve to be like a billionaire
or something hacking facebook with html
all right get your answers in
1 being the worst 10 being the best
i know what i'm going to rate
for me i'm going to give this a rating
of
6.3 and i think that's pretty
pretty fair of course i do because i
gave it right
and that is it for the
reviews once again check out
designcourse.com
enter your email to be notified when i
release this
it's going to be a really exhaustive
just comprehensive way to learn all the
stuff i'm talking about ui and ux design
full courses are going to be worked in
there teaching not just
software like figma in adobe xd and all
that
but also the ui design fundamentals and
a lot of projects will be worked in
there we're going to have
interactive ui design tests that will
really help you develop the eye for all
those ui design fundamentals live
workshops
challenges all of it so that's coming in
several months time
enter your email to be notified check
out my youtube channel
it's a design course youtube.com forward
slash design course
i do this live show several times per
month
um i'm going to be doing it in two days
as well
on friday on my own channel so
definitely check that out
and that is it all right so thanks for
stopping by
if i rated your design and you got mad
because i rated it low
don't worry about it it's just a rating
i'm only one guy
so again if you want to improve
check out i google
uh all the ui design fundamentals i
actually have courses free courses on my
channel
i released one earlier about ui design
earlier this year so
take all these resources and use them to
get better
also check out sites like dribbble.com
those are going to help you with
inspiration and just looking at other
designs can help you
figure things out even on a subconscious
level
and then taking it a step further if you
see a design you really like
just as a matter of practice go into ui
design
software whether that's figma or adobe
xd
and recreate it you know don't don't
claim it's your own just as a matter of
practice recreate the design that's
going to help build in
muscle memory so it's really interesting
i play guitar
i'm trying to learn if i'm ever trying
to learn a crazy solo that's really fast
or difficult or whatever
when i first try it it's it's hard right
but when i go to sleep and then the next
day i try it
all of a sudden it's just right there it
your these neurons that
are they're creating connections while
you're sleeping or even if you just take
a break for an hour
it still happens even then so the design
is the same
way so for those of you who are
struggling
you have to you have to put in the time
uh and you actually have to
to do not just watch me or
follow tutorials or watch the tours you
have to do and i will stop
at this point rambling on all right
thanks a lot everybody and i will